[Music]
every game has things
players love to hate
why the [ __ ] are they
sometimes it's because your favorite
weapon or character
is just stupidly broken or overpowered
sometimes though it's because they're so
terrible
so useless so trashed here that you
cannot
help but obsess over them so these are
the top 10
trash useless low tier absolute
bottom of the ladder picks in esports
at number 10 is the one true lord of
rainbow six siege
to chunker tachanka that's definitely s
tier
fantastic utility with his machine no
i'm just kidding he's definitely d2
chunk is garbage i shouldn't have to
explain this one for you
obviously tsm's r6 coach pogerman
was not very impressed with the operator
and for good reason
before his recent rework tachanka was a
sitting
duck stuck manning an imprecise high
recoil gun
in a game centered around fast-paced
movement and accurate headshots
and in pro play it was hard to see
picking tachanka as
anything other than a joke that's that's
not that's not real that's
that's oh wow he actually lost exactly
ladies and gentlemen it's happened
we do have a tashanka being played for
the first
round of this consulate map after his
most recent rework though
stationary cannon fodder to chunker is
no
more the once trash tier operator might
even be
overpowered
taking our number nine spot we have a
character who is the face of his game
and still manages to be low tier ryu
now before you start flaming us in the
comments i'd like to point out we're not
talking about ryu in general
but rather the ryu in street fighter 5.
we are here with some street fighter 5
wii u gameplay we're going to play some
low tier re oh don't jump at me
but yeah i mean obviously you guys know
wii u is a low tier
in this game and justin wong wasn't the
only person to hold that opinion about
ryu's place
in street fighter 5 season 4. he started
as one of the best
characters in the game but nerf after
nerf has made him
almost worthless just listen to
streamers am kid and match your tv
explain why he's still not scary
you know people are fighting ryu they're
not like scared of ryu especially when
he activates trigger like how many of
you guys
really are scared when we activate speed
trigger to make it like you're supposed
to give him something different yeah
not the same thing but in a different
animation or a different fashion
nah no you're supposed to give him
something new something that is
actually useful ryu might not be the
worst character
in the game right now but his fall from
grace is what earns him a spot on this
list
even ryu devotees like daigo haven't
been able to bring themselves to play
him for
years
coming in at number eight we have viper
a valerian agent who just
pales in comparison to her competition
i'm gonna go ahead and put viper down
here
because literally nobody touches her
that was tense expressing a
pretty common opinion on viper and sure
there are times when she looks
absolutely insane
but when you compare her to the rest of
the agents in the game
she just seems lackluster her best
abilities require fuel
which is just one more thing she has to
worry about and her ultimate
well we'll let hiko tell you more about
that her
alt is just not good her all most of the
time is a liability
i feel like a lot of times it's even
it's it's you're actually putting
yourself in a disadvantage using her all
instead of actually helpful viper has
been one of the worst
agents in valorem since day one and even
though she's received tons of buffs
she's still basically unplayable at a
high level
hopefully one day the toxic avenger
receives a rework that can make her
relevant
and number seven pick teemo started off
as league of legends adorable
mascot unfortunately these days all he
does is mess up my solo queue games
and i promise i'm not the only one who
hates him
if people ever pick this character it
tends to be as a joke
teemo there's the teemo oh how's tivo
into aatrox
oh i mean i imagine it's a hard stop i
mean in what universe
does teemo lose to anything if really i
mean
look teemo probably isn't the worst
champion on the current patch
and he's far from one of the least
played champions in the game
but patch after patch no one wants to
see this little [ __ ] on their
team
he's been so bad on so many patches
he deserves a spot on this list he's
adorable
quiet look at the first blood knocks him
out damage
poison what
barely lives on get the disaster
the teemo is falling he has limited
utility
doesn't bring much to team fights and is
basically worse than
literally any other champion you could
pick instead of him
at least according to streamer scooch
he's easily countered offers almost
nothing in team fights
sucks at split pushing and when you
compare him to every other top laner in
the game he falls short
teemo got on so many players shitless
riot put him in their pen to kill video
for the sole purpose
of letting everyone enjoy seeing him get
punted into the sun by
olaf and of course there's also the
laugh
at number six we have little mac a smash
character who breaks
all the rules of smash in the worst way
possible
he's a character with essentially one
benefit being very strong and having
super armor
and a billion flaws and jokey's opinion
isn't exactly unique in competitive
smash the most
important moments happen off stage
recovering
stopping your opponent's recovery and
guaranteeing a kill offstage are
key to victory little max sucks at
all of that and this is another
character keep in mind that people like
to say is the worst character in the
game but look at that amazing recovery
kind of barely made it back scared of
his teeth but despite how frustrating
maining little mac could be
there are always at least a few gluttons
for punishment out there
and sometimes the payoff is actually
worth the pain
that that's the thing don't worry the
absolute center
from center field and weight into up
till punish
coming in at number five is overwatch's
torbjorn who once had
the most laughably low skill abilities
in the entire game
the only thing going for torbjorn was
his turret but even that was seen as
basically a joke for content creators
like ragtag to memo
awesome here comes the pain
so um how long do you want me to stand
here anyway man
dude are you even there the scandinavian
dwarf was an
easy target to hit struggled against
long-range heroes and when it came to
pro play
calling him off meta would have been an
understatement
the chair you hear is because at the far
top left your screen
defran is picking one hero we have not
seen it in the overwatch league
he's on the tour it's hammer time
after turning into a little bit of a
meme torbjorn
finally got the rework he so desperately
needed
a movement speed bonus some damage
resistance and a firing rate increase
and is actually better now and
thankfully
as blizzard lead developer jeff kaplan
stated they kept the important stuff
intact we
love the way he yells out molten core so
we're keeping that
coming in at number four is pichu an
adorable melee character with a truly
tragic flaw
when dealing attack damage this
miniature pikachu replica
hurts himself a pretty substantial
obstacle for any player
who's not trying to die immediately
pichu is a character that
the game itself seemingly tried to make
the worst character which is kind of
funny
leffen may find it funny but most
prolific players
simply can't be bothered with the
character of pichu's miniscule
competitive caliber
oh no i feel like he gave up
what the hands gave up no way yo
whizzy's like yo
where's the hungrybox group is
looking for a cs go gun that will give
you good damage accuracy
and armor penetration then our third
entry the pp bison
is not the gun for you it does 11 damage
to the chest
11. 10 bullets to kill somebody the most
similar weapon to this thing would
probably be the nerf super soaker
and i notorious isn't wrong devoid of
basically
all of the most essential components of
a good csgo weapon the bison's only
redeeming feature
is its enormous magazine capacity you're
pretty much
only buying this gun when you're just
looking to spray and pray a lot
or respond to a dare on twitter we see
the bison coming in from wonder child i
actually saw someone on twitter
already saying like i dare you to buy a
bias and do the semi-final well
random cs go fan you have had your wish
fulfilled here we go by
on jw right now mowing down there in
middle and here he comes
them all down
number two on our list is apex legends
own resident meme gun
the mozambique the mozambique after five
minutes in the game that's what
that's what i get
i can like i can literally pull the
pillows off my couch right now and find
better loot
some of the weapons highlights until
recently included having virtually
no ammo and doing very little damage
either up close or at a distance
something courage so aptly demonstrated
on stream
me when i'm hitting my enemy with a
mozambique
even the game developers are in on the
joke for april fool's day
respawn gave the players golden
mozambique
a god tier weapon with nine shots a
magazine
instead of the usual three a massive
rate of fire and a
huge damage boost if only for a day
mozambique was king
and streamers were thrilled i got the
gold mozambique
same i got the gold r301 as well
you know you want to give that r3 a one
to eight todd i'll trade it for a gold
mozambique
some claim season six buffs have put an
end to mozambique's uselessness
making it a viable mid-range combat
weapon
but no matter what we will always have
the memes rounding out our list
at number one is the fortnite gun
everyone gets
but no one actually wants the grey
pistol
the pistol is loud so firing it reveals
your location to
everyone in the vicinity its damage and
accuracy are non-existent at long range
and
in close quarters it's just not as good
as a shotgun
the grey pistol is just the worst
because no one even uses it unless it's
all they have as top 5 gaming points out
the pistol is
basically what you go with when there is
literally nothing else available
and it has been this way since the
game's inception according to the
streamer the smith's plays
now don't feel bad for the common pistol
it has grown accustomed
to being at the lowest spot as it's just
really consistently been the worst gun
in the game but it just so happens the
pistol ended up on the top spot
of this list small victories all right
guys now that we have the trash out of
the way
i'm gonna ask you guys to subscribe we
are on the road to
two million subscribers and we would
love it if you're watching this and you
haven't subscribed
to come and join us on that journey so
make sure you are subscribed thanks for
watching my name is danny burke and i'll
see you all in the next video
i'm not uh i'm not a teemo apologist i
don't i just
i just think the meme is over the joke's
gone too far
he's not that bad honestly and i was
looking at his pick rate the other day
there are so many like popular champions
that aren't
played as much as him so this whole meme
that community hates teemo
it's just not true it's not adding up at
all i'm sorry